Let's at the
high level. Let's talk about computer memory.
So here we have a python file again.
When you these are your this is your algorithm.
These are your instructions and when you
save them to file you have a program. So these are the concepts of program.
And here we have temporary storage.
Okay.
When you run this program.
the things that you have declared in
this
program will appear in Temporaries temporary storage
Okay. So for example here we have a function parameter. That would be
put inside temporary storage here. We have a variable
that will be put in temporary storage and so on.
Okay.
now
when the when these items are
put into the temporary storage, they are
not put in.
A particular order or at least not an order you as
a human programmer will be able to appreciate.